welcome to this video yeah I screwed up
my window here not my actual window of
the of the place but the board window
but now I get to get the game started
playing catch rock Tetrarch or something
yep I am but no information in there
about this person so let's see I
recently played this wacky gambar
against the Slav I think okay it's
playing a bit differently that if I go
night if I think that's Nyjah for that
might be a problem actually so maybe a
four that's a good reaction to this
gambit maybe this guy is a little bit
too strong to try to try this line then
what's compensation is not not really
clear a four is making sure that be five
is not happening but and one problem is
that 95 is always answered by lagi for
that some that's not too nice maybe I
can go h3 here prevent that it was a bit
reluctant to play efore because of
possible night before to d3 here it
comes so 95 now probably go bishop is 6
I wonder if 85 and creat a 4 as an idea
or it's a for an idea you might have 97
okay damn that looks like a very fishy
pawn sacrifice no yeah I just I just
tried that out recently in some some
blitz games and it worked out very okay
but I played it against much Rica much
Rico opposition and they frankly I'm
didn't didn't play it right this looks a
far more problematic but maybe I can do
something with this pawns in the center
possible f5 the right moment but that
really has to be the right moment like
it's definitely okay here maybe you can
even play f6 am I are interesting so g4
or maybe g-form it's a bit more
aggressive than King age 22 have f5 as a
possibility so where'd you go to eat two
or three maybe to e2 to keep c4 under
under tag and f5s serve is over it it
gets to be interesting uh-huh so what is
he shooting for after f5 f5 is going
back
yeah I guess I have to slow moves won't
won't cut it yeah so he's giving up
giving the piece that's an interesting
practical decision maybe not a bad one
so let's get this out quickly he's
having three pawns for the peace and
very active pieces so it's kind of kind
of a logical way to play let's take
gameplay Queen here attacking f7
undertaking a sound so I might win a
pond or queen you form but Queen d4 I
can take and play with you one okay so i
can take the pawn and I think I will and
now there's no particular reason not to
take it
yeah it looks ok I've got rooked you one
next so I kind of I think build wiggle
to myself out of it or he he did I don't
know he definitely helped me I had my
doubts about the position now it seems
very very unclear probably quite good
for white actually but still very very
tricky to play you see going 493
possibly am but i still i think i can go
here night is 3 i'm checking rook checks
Andrew gap three should be possible I
think don't see a drawback really Queen
on a seven is attacking the night as
well and it doesn't have a great way at
the moment there to cover it with this
Queen if he goes Queen g5 I check on be
a play Queen f4 I have one upon on a
seven which makes a the endgame quite an
attractive prospect okay that's
interesting can check him take be seven
but is that really the way to go
hmm the ship Bishop f1 maybe what he
will take that with the night that's not
good I wonder if he has a great move on
queen bee seven really I don't don't
don't see one at the moment
92 Kings you to check them may I check
on the towards a bit annoying yeah it is
hmm there's some way to get the Queen
into the game back into the game that
the check then drop key to this is
problematic
my queen is cut off now my queen is
really cut off do I get it back somehow
time margin take 92 I can play 20 30 I
didn't look at that move at all so here
92 rocket III
hmm I don't know what that is might be a
draw oh I looked at move rook g3 is
night everyone oh no that's not good
check
yeah my piece coordination is not good
really isn't and b2 is so falling yeah
that's a real issue the courier problem
I spoiled a very good position there
that was very nice actually I had a
pretty big advantage I think but maybe
I'm wrong I don't know check maybe a
room
I thought it was very nice at one point
but I could be could be wrong reading
you can take take this pawn check mm-hmm
what is this kind of position I don't
know check black for fits on time what
is this is just a draw when I had home
do you draw around no it's win no it's
the wing he's in Zeus one yeah I keep
all the pants well wasn't so sure were
there but yeah it's it's it's winning
winning in fact I thought that that I
thought he really unbelievable group
here cc5 was a cute yeah queen bee seven
here and what is the point look f2
unlight it to whistle move yeah I kind
of probably lost lost it a little bit
here 19 20 s good I didn't see that one
it looks it looks very scary check Wow
methods I mean what kind of line is that
and then I'm checking here chattin white
mates first yeah that that's super
difficult so here here and now I didn't
really see how to defend took took their
King h1 as a defense how am I supposed
to see this one really it's interesting
okay this is nice and here 90 x attiki
seven and now i have my my own threats
with a draw well okay let's look at the
opening a little bit yeah this g6 is
actually a good reply I think to to this
gambit which seems to be white fushime
to be perfectly honest yeah f-14 chances
maybe just take you 1 now not keep the
Queen's on but okay that cannot be bad
93 also came into consideration and now
we are the engine is just going back to
this evidence and claims a huge
advantage for black I was thinking that
after Bishop f4 it's not that clear yeah
but okay Quincy 786 check check as the
point i don't have Bishop e3 and this is
a bit messy but probably good four
blagghhhhh yeah i'm not getting a check
made in or something he has very nice
pieces in the center and hear the engine
is just and basically uncle' i ax equal
i was expecting Queenie forward yeah
very very messy and basically am yeah
basically I'm like playing roulette
there's a metal matter of luck a little
bit too
the right ones okay well thanks for
watching